eu transport ministers have agreed on a
proposal assigning new tasks to the
european railway agency and streamlining
its processes
the agency would act as a one-stop shop
for authorizing vehicles for
cross-border operations and for issuing
safety certificates to railway
undertakings across member states
the proposed regulation is part of the
fourth railway package published by the
european commission
this constitutes a first step
we need to move on to
next steps
in the near future
so that we can try to complete a common
european policy for rail transport in
europe that's going to have a big impact
on the economy
and on development in the eu
ministers have also adopted their
position on a proposal to develop a
coordinated eu approach to research and
innovation in the rail sector
the idea is to set up a public private
partnership shift to rail to support the
development of better rail services in
europe and boost the rail sector's
competitiveness
in other developments the council also
held a policy debate on competitive and
resource efficient urban mobility